pinched nerves back and neck pains
headaches migraines no problems Spinal
Care of Nevada the sponsors of this
segment can help with the their modern
low-force Chiropractic and joining us to
talk about that is Dr tuck Cosmic
welcome thank you for having me I love
the fact that this is modern low Force
tell us a little about this kind of
Chiropractic okay so a low Force
Chiropractic basically is there's no
loud popping there's no twisting it's
low Force as it says this is the tool
that we employ this is the arthro stim
and this allows us to get to a specific
joint and apply a gentle adjustment to
the spine so things like headaches neck
pain back pain
patients really appreciate the less
aggressive means of curing those
symptoms I was telling you sometimes you
see some of those really abrupt
movements and it's terrifying buying and
this sounds like the gentle way to take
care of so many problems
um I when you when you treat people and
it's not just for back pain like you
mentioned headaches other things what
what do you see the most when you treat
your patients so what we treat is
something called a subluxation now
that's a fancy way of saying a bone is
out of place okay so if you have a bone
out of place in the neck that's going to
contribute things to neck pain headaches
ringing in the ears even numbness and
tingling down the arms if you have a
bone out of place in the low back that's
going to cause back pain sacral pain
sciatic pain and so by applying a gentle
adjustment to those areas we realign the
bone we take away that pain from the
patient and they can live a better life
this is so fascinating can you show us a
little bit about like how it works
exactly yeah absolutely so like I said
if a bone is out of place up top on the
neck you just come under here
and then that's it and that's it that
seems like it actually might feel good
compared to the alternative right yep
now tell us a little bit about what the
offer that you have for people that want
to come in now so what we
um excel at is a comprehensive two-day
workup now normally this is hundreds of
dollars but today we're offering it for
thirty seven dollars and that includes a
detailed history extensive examination
and a set of digital x-rays which really
are the best films in our field today
and that allows us to get a complete
picture of the patient for 30 37 correct
wow so so for the first 20 callers uh
this offer is available uh for 37. and
where are you located we're located in
Summerlin and we also have an office in
Henderson amazing thank you so much for
joining us Dr tuck thank you to Spinal
Care of Nevada for sponsoring this
segment again 1930 Village Center Circle
you can call
702-566 hope it's finalcareofnevada.com
that special offer the exam and digital
x-rays for 37 this is a 270 dollar value
but only for the first 20 callers we'll
be right back
[Music]